Мощун невеличке село поблизу
Києва на початку вторгнення Росії в
Україну Мощун став одним із форпостів
які допомогли українським військовим
виграти битву за Київ саме на цих
вулицях ЗСУ розгромили елітні бригади
російської армії про запеклі бої які
тривали майже місяць і досі нагадує
суцільна руїна у селі жодної вцілілої
хати Тут в нас був дом був можна сказать
да оце в нас був до 136
МТ залишилося один фундамент 10 березня
2022 року у самий розпал боїв родина
гавриленків втратила все майно три
ракети попало прямо в хату а дальше Все
воно пішло по цепочки там сарай згорів
трактор пішов і все остальне тепер сім'я
мешкає у модульному будинку який надали
українські
благодійники нас там шестеро чоловік
батько з одної сторони а ми з ції Ну так
як чоловіка немає в нас в ЗСУ до четверо
в одній комнаті Юлія каже за тимчасове
житло дуже вдячна але найбільше мріє
відбудувати власне і хапається за кожну
можливість Уже понад рік подає документи
на програми з відбудови проте у
відповідь ніхто нічого не каже каже
ніхто нічого не цейє чекайте і все Ну
ждіть Ну чесно Забули що Мощун існує тож
живуть у модульному будинку від
безвиході А це каже Юлія неабияке
випробування з дворічною дитиною на
руках Як тебе звати скажи Мене звать
Гриша да
да Гриша Привіт потрогай потрогати оба
вставай
зводити нову оселю власним коштом
гавриленки можливості не мають За
підрахунками Юлії необхідно щонайменше 3
мльн грвень для багатодітної родини сума
непідйомна Тим паче чимало грошей з
сімейного бюджету йде на потреби
чоловіка який служить в ЗСУ чоловік у
мене щас в лімані от ну служить 68
бригада Ну каже дуже-дуже тяжело
приїхали вони і за дані все обгорівше
все це йому перекинула гроші він пішов
купив ну 10 000 дуже мало це купить
штани берце купить і все остальне тож
Юлія чекає і на повернення чоловіка з
фронту і на обіцяну відбудову а от сусід
гавриленків пан Олексій який також
подавався на різноманітні програми з
відбудови зокрема і на є відновлення
швидко зневірився Віта так власним
коштом замінив вікна та відремонтував
котельню воно все вигріло але оці всі
частці Мороз ударив ще осталася вода і
воно порозморажувало ну короче
порепались труби порепались насоси то
прийшлось наливаєш воду бачиш Де тече
спускаєш заварюєш загалом на ремонт
пішло понад 80 000 грн і ця сума була би
більшою в рази каже якби не міжнародна
допомога запід птримки ООН пану Олексію
безоплатно замінили дах і матеріал
привезли безкоштовно і все зробили
безкоштовно Ну я хлопц так то кофе то
чай таке то була риба наловлена то я ри
риби гостив їх Ну кришашлася десь
наверно тисяч під 100 гривень якщо не
більше найбільше допомоги від
українських та іноземних волонтерів
Мощун отримував то рік одразу після
деокупації Київщини проте поступово
інтерес до до долі села зменшувався нині
волонтери в мощуні рідкість кажуть
місцеві тож змушені самотужки шукати
спонсорську підтримку приміром ось цей
модульний будинок родині ющенків
подарували далекі родичі зі Сполучених
Штатів нам ключі вручили 25 декабря на
Рождество католическее а зимувать не
зимували просто про включали свет щоб
воно просохало бо не було каналізації
було сильно тут мокро дожі не могли ми
круги закопать а закопали їх токо це
літом Коли вже воно подсохло тоді ми
доробили каналізацію і перейшли сюди
[музика]
жить ну удобний дом да як нема нічого то
Слава Богу що так зводити новий будинок
власним коштом Юрій не поспішає каже
гарантія на модульний 8 років тож
сподівається за цей час отримати до гу
від держави таку вже не построюв конечно
на 115 квадрав квадратов
8090 думав Так строїть весной потом
менеговорили родичі щоб я пока не строїв
думаю Хай ще пережду трохигод Ну може що
остановиться тоді буду строїть если
государство не поможе буду сам строїть
жінка мене береглива трохи
насбирали у травні мощуном прокотилася
радісна звістка село увійшло до
сціальної урядової програми з
комплексної відбудови як анонсували в
уряді шість зруйнованих населених
пунктів із різних регіонів України
повністю трансформують за принципом
краще ніж було Утім участь мощуна у
проекті ій досі під питанням гальмує
відновлення застаріла документація
зокрема неактуальний генплан села
затвердити його можна під час сесії
гостомильської селищної ради проте Ну
просто нема сесії воєнне время сесія не
мо не собираеться ми два раза один
шмигалю
писали за старости туда сходили всі а
потом один одне прохання до Зеленського
щоб якось посодействовали що щоб це все
Бо так Ну іначе не получається староста
села про проблему знає і переконує
найближчим часом її вирішать Утім коли
саме наразі невідомо не підписаний
генплан
нема повноважень військової
адміністрації ну на цим працюють скажем
начальник міської адміністрації Він
працює добре ну тобто сказали що
вирішить це питаннячекаєте так Да ми
чекаємо бачите що перед нами планіровка
будинків які куда Кому що як ставиться
тим часом у селі почали ремонтувати
дорогу асфальт кладуть прямісінько біля
воріт Юлії тиждень як вони роблять цю
дорогу там десь труби перебили там десь
електричество перебило Ну пока терпимо
Вибачте ну Час іде війна ві ну в країні
йде війна вони строять дорогу Ну вона не
потрібна люди осталися без будинків бе
без житла без
нічого і як дальше Воно буде Ну то ж
разом із трьома дітьми і стареньким
батьком Юлія готується зимувати в
модульному будинку втім сподівається що
наступну зиму зустрічатиме вже у власній
відбудованій оселі все
покапока з усіма прощається да
що ти хочеш собі новий будинок хочемо
хочемо ми новий будинок Ну нічого не
[музика]
виходить
I